[Music]
in controversial ad news submitted by
Juneau from Irvine I like that I know
him Gina you know odd you know from
Irvine I like my boobie guy my boobie
holy should I saw that I can stop
laughing oh yeah it's not your story
that sounds I mean she looks at words
and then she makes like a sentence out
of that word so this person's last name
it was a add a new mah Bo u bi ma boo be
boo I saw like please don't touch my boo
boo I feel so lost its humble mumbling
you must watch Gina's stories pretty
good sometimes sometimes ma bow B movie
please sir stop touching my boo me God
if he probably made you got made up or
made fun of so much in school
I'm sorry ma boo be dead but he's so
rich yo know that he was he was yeah
those are Beverly Hills
no he's leasing like everything over
there he's rich so you turned that rage
of getting void into being the biggest
real estate guy who's laughing now all
the back now yeah it's not my boo be
even Halle yo bougie you probably look
at my Instagram's like shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you're poor I like how it's time
to look at yours should attack I'm just
so popular that everyone was he could
have been your friend
Nike receives backlash over a new ad
campaign featuring Colin Kaepernick a
frenetic this is so good I saw this but
I don't 49ers former football player
ballplayer quarterback quarterback it
was the one that took an ear I didn't
wanna like during the whole season like
yeah mm-hmm I don't know what the
outrage is am I wrong am I wrong people
are saying that he whenever the the
national anthem come or when that
national anthem came on he took a knee
and that's disrespectful to our country
yeah but other people are like no like
our country you have a freedom of speech
he can do whatever he wants yeah you
know and it was nearly four but are they
mad because night he's the face of Nike
like what's
that outrage from people and I also
understand that yeah you have your own
choices but then now it seems like
people are really and I don't know what
the new outrage is about its the
Conservatives like her Republicans are
like why are you supporting this - that
took a knee during the anthem so they're
like he's not a real American he's not a
good because Colin Kaepernick is the
face of the new ad campaign that was
just released yeah
through Nike so then there is just
resurfacing on the ship that they were
already angry the thing is people didn't
know he was still sponsored towards Nike
because like he's the one that has his
face on it yeah I see yeah have you seen
what it says - yeah yeah so the word the
words part I get - I just thought like
there's something deeper cuz it was just
something to happen in the past that it
was his personal choice
he didn't sexually harass anyone punch
anyone shoot anybody
it's bread - Oh like all of NFL and like
everyone was like taking a knee yeah but
there's no physical damage to people for
sure for me I didn't saw I understood
the outrage then but then now when it
came to Nike and like up so I meant in
powerlifting right and there's a bunch
of athletes at ice that I follow that
are like I will never wear Nike ever
again I'm like what the [ __ ] like it was
just such a level of anger like just the
whole controversy has been skewed - like
they're seeing it as a direct hit at
America but that's not it
also people are viewing at Nike versus
America almost well yeah because of
Kaepernick oh but isn't it American to
peacefully protest yeah isn't that what
that's what I don't understand well I
mean no because you have to think about
the Americans that have been here for
generations that are like hey my dad and
my grandpa my great good grandpa and all
of them died for our freedom and then
this [ __ ] guy who they probably are
being racist towards are like he's not
gonna respect that like that's not a
[ __ ] America but I'm gonna burn in a
flag though yeah it's not even that
extreme see this the same thing the same
way as Rosa Parks sitting in the front
of the bus instead of sitting in the
back and even though it was
disrespectful or even illegal at the
time yeah it was a good point that she
yes thank you
and in this case - I see it as yeah I
can kind of see that it's disrespectful
but I don't see it fully disrespectful
because he's not saluting he's not
putting his hand over his heart and
standing but he's also not like putting
up the middle finger while he's like
[ __ ] walking think about it to bow down
to something - like that is also kind of
humbling like he's not just like turning
his back either you know like even him
putting his head like that is super
respectful for me you know what I mean
that I'm just like wired like I I'm with
you guys like I don't understand yeah I
just like the [ __ ] that's coming from me
because people are now burning their
[ __ ] it's like hey don't [ __ ] you
already paid for it video this dude that
i retweeted like it was like was he
doing like burning his basketball shorts
oh it was so he's like this is this is
because of you Nike I'm gonna burn my
shoes and he find you such hot - hot
[ __ ] adidas is probably like [ __ ] yeah
bird goes Nikes now that we go by our
[ __ ]
don't you think in like six months to a
year though he's gonna be by Nikes
exactly burn them and he was like is
this really gonna do it sorry what is it
I'd even say I don't even know this is
what it says Colin Kaepernick's face and
that says believe in something even if
it means sacrificing everything just do
it
that fool looks like he makes a bomb
swarm up what is Kaepernick Irish
predictable he looks like his like
hummus recipe at some point it's like he
got the schwarmann yeah but I mean I do
get what people are saying because they
didn't have to make him the face of this
campaign with those words because they
have so many ambassadors so I feel like
it would have been like a little bit
more chill if they went with someone who
didn't hug them yeah I could kind of see
how it it looks like Nike is now taking
a side instead of being neutral and out
of politics so that's probably what
triggered a lot of people to cuz it's
like man what the [ __ ] Nike but why
can't they
beside it's just weird he was adopted by
the way okay because it's weird for a
company to be so exclusive or inclusive
meaning like yeah it's it's more like
you just don't expect companies to do
that like it's not that they can't take
aside that's a big they're supposed to
stay kind of big they're not supposed to
but you don't want to alienate people is
the thing people are saying that Nike
decided to make this move because it's a
risky move and in order to stay relevant
you have to make risky moves so then
it's more of like a business move in
order to stay relevant and stay ahead
what the outrage and I do understand
those I follow up on to like military IG
pages and for them I think they're
really pissed at the wording where it's
it what it said like he sacrificed
everything and there's another former
football player named Pat Tillman yeah
and during time of war he quit the NFL
joined the army became an Army Ranger
and he actually passed away yeah so
they're like this is someone that
actually sacrificed they should have put
him on the front page like yeah like
this guy he didn't sacrifice he's alive
like that's not sacrificing what I mean
like everyone's career I guess because
he's not plan to anything but when you
use like words when you use words like
that yeah it's this I so I can actually
see where that outreach is coming from
there's also a lot of military guys too
that are like I have no problem with
this but it's these civilians that are
trying to like speak on behalf of the
military and be all like yeah like I
fought for his freedom of speech so
don't use that against for your agenda
using the military like he's
disrespected on't use that so is
anything happening tonight be like do
they have to apologize is there stopped
going out there's a dog have gone down
it's like my 3% or something yeah Elon
Musk [ __ ] does more damage to Tesla
than this incident ever did wait did you
guys cover the whole story of like Elon
the girl being Azealia Banks being and
yeah wait weren't you in details what oh
you were your girlfriend and then the
girlfriend never showed and then he was
tripping on acid and then oh he said
he's an interesting [ __ ] my
friend goes to a Burning Man and saw him
in the orgy tent are you serious
he was getting all kinds of [ __ ] gay
Burning Man oh gosh interesting um I
don't know I guess they only I don't
think they do the standard visual test
like but I really hope Nike doesn't
apologize I'm so sick of companies
apologizing for like everything to
because you know they don't mean it yeah
I got mad what would you like to see
Mike you do have like off campaign
assist just [ __ ] it that's black beans
that's bad for the teens we're gonna
start [ __ ] each other not just [ __ ]
you know like just do it before I was
like [ __ ] it we've already been using
that like I remember when I was in high
school I would have all these condoms of
different brands oh my gosh are there
any companies that you guys actually
boycott it cuz we always hear about boys
Oh were you actually like I did
purposely boy out of my er uh well I
mean a lot of these companies do this
right where they means to treat animals
and [ __ ] but they were just won't do
that yeah it was I want a boycott
Monsanto but I don't even know which
fruit to boycott why why do we want to
boycott them boy but Monsanto boy but
date they [ __ ] up a lot of like well
they're just kind of like the Mafia of
farming oh yeah do that then yeah do it
yeah nobody - I don't know what though
like I don't know which grains which
don't even eat anymore yeah I'm like how
do you boy yeah how do you boycott their
grains I don't know Soylent baby
I don't know plant your own water just
water only your own [ __ ] grab my own
[ __ ] you're the start of your father
Monsanto see I know you get from Vietnam
somewhere make sure it's like fresh
seeds from me they're like a Japanese
company it sounds Japanese no Italian
sounds like California when some punch
so not cultured I want a boycott stuff I
just don't want to do the research I
don't know I used to be like pissed off
because like if one C or whatever makes
a move right I'm I'll [ __ ] them forever
but then if you think about how many
people are affected by that job yeah I'm
just like nah that's not fun that's not
right because of their higher ups but
I'm sure every single company has some
dirt everything yeah all of them did
every single one so if your boy we all
got we got dirt here no we don't just
carry i remember in junior high like
tommy hilfiger said something about
Asians or whatever and like a lot of my
friends are like oh I'm not gonna wear
it in my mouth give a [ __ ] I still
bought their [ __ ] the USC of Abercrombie
and Fitch said that he doesn't want ugly
people wearing his clothing only
attractive people and this fool is the
ugliest [ __ ] ever who said this
Abercrombie and Fitch is CEO it was a
terribly style I remember one of those
are entertainer those yeah and American
Eagle it's one of those but yeah you
said that I only want pretty people no
fat people no uglies but did that work
because now they're like in the [ __ ]
all right yeah I've heard them a lot I
feel like nothing else worked like
they're trying to boycott in and out
right now yeah but they also donate to
Democrats it's so stupid I actually
tweet at the stupid politician and I'm
all like you're waging a [ __ ] war you
can't win you can't tell Californians to
boycott in and out that's like telling
them to [ __ ] bite their grandma's
ankle and not eat avocado yeah so the
point of that joke is the only crazy
people will do it like only crazy people
are gonna boycott in and out I like that
bite the grandma thing yeah
[Music]
[Music]